so are you trying to
come up with what type of youtube
channel you should have i know it can
feel
overwhelming when you think about
investing your time and your money
and your hard work into coming up with a
youtube channel and
from being on youtube for over five
years helping grow a youtube channel to
over a million subscribers and help
thousands of creators narrow down and
get clarity
on their youtube channel i am here to
help you today and if we're just meeting
my name is heather torres i'm part of
the think team and i help run think
marketing and you're watching the think
marketing q a right now
but we're gonna dive into learning what
are three
youtube channel ideas for beginners uh
i'm excited to share this with you today
and if you're just watching
on the live let me know where you're
watching from and if you're watching on
the replay
go ahead and drop a comment below and
let me know what your channel is about
but
if we're just meeting my name is heather
torres and i'm part of the think team
and
our mission is to help you build your
influence
with online video and this is just a
couple of the students we've helped with
online video learn what channels are
working what channels aren't working and
help them go to over a hundred thousand
subscribers
be able to quit their job and go full
time that's the mission that we are on
here
at think and i'm excited to share with
you today the three
youtube channel ideas for beginners and
we're gonna start with number one which
is probably
one of the most popular types of
channels that people think about
which is a vlog channel let me know in
the comments below if you have a
vlogging channel but this is channel
idea number one and we're going to be
going through the pros
and the cons of each of these different
types of channels because
i really think it's important when you
are getting into youtube when you're
starting that channel
to really identify you know is this
worth it is it worth putting my time and
my energy
and all of the hard work that's going to
go into it so number one is a vlog
channel now vlog channels are great
types of channels
and i can share with you that this is
casey neistat he's
probably one of the most known vloggers
on youtube he's got over 12 million
subscribers he makes some amazing
videos so this shows proof that vlog
channels can be successful this is just
one style
of channels here's nikki phillippi she
does a lifestyle vlogging channel and
she's been so successful
to reach over 1 million subscribers she
does youtube full-time
full-time vlogging and creating
lifestyle content but let's go over
what are some of the pros when it comes
to doing
a vlog style channel well one of them is
that you can become a storyteller
that's right you can tell a story and
let me know if you're like me
i love watching good movies and the
reason i love watching good movies
is because they have good stories they
understand
how a movie should start with the the
drama or the anticipation and then
there's an arc there's some type of
of a mission that that the character is
on there's a climax to the movie and
then usually it ends with
you know a great end of the story and
that's what i love about vlog style
channels you really get to
bring someone along on the journey with
you when you're doing a vlog
style channel another great pro to
having a vlog style channel is that you
can be really relational
let me know in the comments who are some
of your favorite vloggers but i think
one thing i love so much about vlogging
channels
is that you get to be behind the scenes
you're kind of
the fly on the wall to someone else's
life and
uh right now i'm fully obsessed with van
life
vlogs van life vlogs it means like
you're following people who are
traveling around the world
living in like a sprinter van that's
converted
it's so cool and my favorite vlogs to
watch are
van life vlogs because i'm behind the
scenes i'm seeing
you know the nitty-gritty of when the
engine breaks down or how they redesign
things or
you know what they're doing with that
vlog and
that's just one of my favorite ones and
i love it because you get to be so
relational it's the day-to-day it's
behind the scenes
it's really that lifestyle type of
content but
there are some cons when it comes
to vlog style channels i'm not fully
against vlog style channels but
if you are trying to do this as a side
hustle if you're trying to
make this into a full-time career then
as a youtube coach i want to coach you
and say
vlogging might not be the best way to do
it and here's why
because it's hard to batch produce your
content
now what's batch producing well batch
producing is something that i myself
have to do when i'm creating content
because
i'm a mom of three i'm a homeschooling
mom i'm running a media company i'm
working with a team i'm doing all these
things there's no way
i would be able to produce a vlog every
single day
i do content in batches meaning i sit
down
and all film not just one video not just
two videos
usually three to five videos anytime i'm
gonna sit down and put my makeup on
anytime i'm gonna sit down and script a
video i'm gonna do more than one
because my content can go further now if
you have a vlog style
it really is kind of real-time content
right you're behind the scenes
you're telling the story of what's
happening in your life but
that is every single day that's what
you're doing every single day with vlog
style content so you can't
batch vlog style content it can also
take longer to build influence
you know vlog style content with the way
the youtube algorithm works
isn't necessarily discoverable content
discoverable
yeah it's harder to get discovered in
the content uh
in the youtube algorithm when you have
vlog style content and that's just
really related to the titles
and the thumbnails and the topics of the
video that aren't as
easily found by people who are coming to
the platform
that are putting in a search putting in
a search in the search box
and looking for something so it's it
takes longer to build
influence now are there unicorns on the
on the platform absolutely right you'll
have people that'll come on
all of a sudden they're you know getting
all these views that is
very rare and if you're someone who is
just starting on youtube
as someone who has been on the platform
for a while i want to make sure that you
know the pros and cons of this type of
content
the last is it can take a little bit
longer to make money
so if you're on the chant if you're on
the platform and you really want this to
be a career like let me know in the chat
right now are you
are you serious about youtube do you
want youtube to be your full-time job do
you want to be able to create content
when you want where you want work with
cool brands
work with good people right become a
creative entrepreneur
if that's your goal then a vlog style
channel
it's gonna just take longer to get to
the money part of youtube now
you can make money through adsense you
can make money through brand deals
but being able to build that influence
first
that's usually the hardest thing and the
money is usually harder
on the back side now can you be
successful on youtube absolutely as a
vlogger
benji travis is one of our is part of
video influencers
and him and his wife judy have been
vloggers for
years they're very successful it's the
job that they do but
i want you to know the pros and cons of
vlogging all right number two
or sorry let me go to this your content
if you are a vlogger is actually about
you instead of being about them
so when you're thinking about if
vlogging is what you'd like to do
if turning the camera on you and taking
them along through your day is what you
want to do remember
it's harder to break through because
your content is about
you and not about them
number two number two you can actually
start a review channel
so this is a really great type of
channel to have on the platform because
youtube loves channels that help people
and here's
uh an example right here marquis brown
he does let me know if you know who this
is
he does uh cell phone reviews and he is
such an artist and a great creative
and he's built his channel to 12 million
subscribers there's a ton of review
channels on the platform and they can be
very
successful so let's go through what are
some of the pros and cons
of a review channel number one it can
lead to
income streams meaning when you start
doing a review channel
and you sign up for say amazon
affiliates or other affiliate marketing
programs
you can start making money off of very
low
uh um view count type videos so it's
very easy
to go from reviewing a product to
actually making an income
on that product with a review channel
also
it's really helpful information and one
thing that youtube
loves is channels that are answering
questions
remember youtube is owned by google
which means that
they are a searched based system the
algorithm the machine
behind youtube is all about what people
are actually typing
into and what they're actually
interested in and so if you're reviewing
say
watches or cars or um or
cell phones or whatever it is that
you're reviewing
you can be the answer to someone else's
problems now what about the cons well
the cons
is actually how do you get those review
items and
we've had people in our community that
have tried to you know reach out to
companies and get items and it's just
not as easy so
unless you already have a lot of the
things you want to review it's
not really the easiest type of channel
to get started with but
i'm excited because number three is
educational
and as an educational channel number
three of the video ideas that i want to
give you today is an educational
channel and this is our favorite
type of youtube channel an educational
channel is our favorite type of youtube
channel and i'm going to tell you why
but let me show you this is think media
now think media
is one of the uh channels that we run
and
we help people with the tips and the
tools
for growing their influence online we
help them with the cameras and the gear
we do a lot of how how-to videos how-to
is education what about my other channel
which is a homeschooling channel
it's how to homeschool it's the it's the
how to get started it's a educational
channel now this can be in so many
different
niches and we're going to talk about
that but here's mary's nest
you saw mary at the beginning she just
passed a hundred thousand subscribers
this year she's now at 290
000 subscribers mary helps with
traditional
cooking for the modern pioneer she does
things like broths and sourdoughs
she is a how-to channel a educational
channel and then there's total dog
they're a local business
in las vegas and they help you uh
with your dog's obedience they help
train dogs who
uh kind of get left to the side because
they're overly aggressive or
they're just not able to be trained this
is a company
that helps you with your dogs they're
how to
help you train your dog now this is fly
ride chris
has a company where he helps you with
the lighting of your car
custom lighting is what chris has built
his entire
youtube channel on and with that he's
gone full time with less than a hundred
thousand subscribers
that's right he was able to quit his job
and go full time with his youtube
channel
just on custom lighting are you seeing
the value of an
educational channel now here are some
pros let's walk through the pros
you can go full time faster with a
smaller channel
if you don't know uh sean the ceo of
think
he was able to go full time on youtube
with less than 20
000 subscribers why because he's an
educational
channel you can have multiple streams of
income
what i love about educational channels
is right away you open yourself
up to being able to be hired as a coach
or set yourself up for affiliate
marketing or create your own
buy bun your own online education
program right
you have so many ways right off the bat
to be able to
have multiple streams of income which
would mean that you're
leveraging your time so that you can
work less
and do more right you're able to batch
your content
i told you that myself as a mom of three
trying to run a company and do all the
things there's no way i could have a
channel
that would not allow me to be able to
batch produce content so you're able to
create multiple videos at one time and
then
you can create content that solves a
problem
hear me think this is critical
our job as entrepreneurs is to solve
a problem so my question to you is well
what problem do you solve
and who do you want to help when you
think about choosing a niche and you
think about what it you know how do i
figure out what the channel is
i love so many different things right
let me know are you like me
and you love so many different things
you could start five channels right now
but if you had to pick one if you're
just getting started
and you choose either a vlog channel
review channel or my favorite an
educational channel
and then you decide what niche you want
to be in i want you to really think
about this and write this down
who do i help and how do i help them
what
community do i want to serve and how do
i want to serve them best
when i think about going back and
starting my homeschool channel i was so
scared i was nervous i i never produced
videos on youtube yet
but i knew that there was so many hours
as a new homeschool mom that i really
just
was spending researching and i just
wished that there was someone
answering the questions that i had i was
a working mom and a lot of the
homeschooling moms that i was reading
about that was the only thing they were
doing so i didn't feel like i could
relate
i also am an entrepreneur and i think
differently right kind of outside the
box of
normal traditional education and i was
finding a lot of
other moms that were thinking that way
but they weren't producing
video content i was reading blogs and i
was on pinterest but i wasn't seeing it
on
video and so when i started my youtube
channel i knew
that i wanted to pick a niche that i
could serve
now you might be thinking well i mean
i'm not an expert
and hear me friend i'm not an expert in
homeschooling either
but what i am is i am a friend
i am a guide and when i think about what
you should be
choosing for your niche you want to
choose something that's proven
and profitable and why did i decide
homeschooling well because
education is proven and profitable right
and so when you think about
where should i go if i'm starting an
educational style channel
i want you to think who do i help and
how do i help them
and again think about is this a proven
and profitable niche what does proven
mean proven means are other people doing
what i want to do
you know we get uh customers here or
community members here at think
and they'll say yeah but there's already
this type of channel or there's already
someone doing that and i go that's great
that means it's proven that means
there's an audience that means that your
voice
could be another voice in that community
and what about profitable
well i mean are other people selling
things are
you buying things in that niche right
like i think about someone that came to
us
and he loves biking like he loves like
dirt biking and all that and he's like i
think i'm gonna talk about um
i think i'm gonna talk about taxes i'm
like but you
own like seven bikes right like let's go
into something that is proven and
profitable you're able to make money off
of that and so
thinking about what that looks like and
again you don't necessarily need to be
you don't necessarily need to be the
actual expert
you can be a friend you could be a guide
you could be a mentor and you can be a
leader
these are other ways to think about it
when you're going into a new space
when you're starting a new youtube
channel when you're thinking about
helping people
a lot of times we have this imposter
syndrome that comes in come on let me
know if this is what you feel like
or you think who am i to be doing this
why would someone want to listen to me
then i need you to hear me i know that
you have a message inside
i know that you actually have been there
have experienced it
have wished there was someone that was
there that was the friend the guy the
mentor the teacher
and you have something that you can
share with this audience
and so as you start to choose out your
niche as you decide
what channel you want to start i just
want to encourage you
that there's going to be an experiment
season that you may not get it right
right away
but if you just start knowing where
you're going if you decide i'm going to
do either a vlog channel or review
channel or an educational channel
education please uh that there's the
opportunity
in the long run for you to do this
full-time there's an opportunity for you
to have this as a side hustle right now
and be able to make this into a
full-time career and
if you want to learn how you can do this
if you're like yep that's me i want to
figure that out but i want to learn how
to do youtube the right way
like when i get started i don't want to
flounder by myself i really want someone
that could be there that can help me
with that
then i definitely recommend that your
next step is to go to
thinkmasterclass.com
where we have a one hour free youtube
class this is a youtube class where
we're gonna teach you what video ideas
you should be doing
we're gonna be teaching you uh um how to
choose that profitable niche right like
where should you like
what niche should you actually get we're
gonna teach you why
now is the time for you to be going all
in on youtube
to not sit back to not watch others do
this but for you to take that step
and start doing that and in the end of
the class we actually offer you the
opportunity to go deeper with us
inside of a world class academy called
video ranking academy so
your next step though if you're like yes
i'm in i've chosen my uh
category i want to be in i know what
channel i want to start i need to know a
little bit more
then think master class is actually your
next step all right we're actually going
to be getting into
the q a portion of today but let me know
if you're getting value out of this
video right now
hit that like button and if you're not
already subscribed here on the think
marketing
podcast on the think marketing show and
the channel all of the things
then you definitely want to hit the
subscribe button wherever you're
listening to this
uh video on and we're going to jump into
the q a part of today's
show and what that looks like is there
is a link dropped inside of the chat if
you're watching this
live we have uh the team inside of the
chat right now and you can actually come
on video with me
and we'll do a little coaching session a
little question answer session
um and we will get right into that so uh
let's see let's see who's coming on
first looks like uh we're gonna bring
angela on
hi angela how are you
let's see is angela know she's on oh
okay
we'll remove angela and we'll i'm
looking over here let's see who's up
bran okay there's angela here we go hi
angela how are you
uh yep
i can hear you can you hear me
hello hello i'm good how are you
good i think i caught you off guard i'm
so sorry about that how you doing
i can you know what i've got three
devices going i'm going to take you off
of a
all right
i'm going to bring brandon on i'll bring
you right back on say again
can you hear me hold on hold on hold on
let me take you off of that
okay awesome i'm going to bring brandon
on really quick and then
hey brandon how you doing doing good
thanks for having me
on yes we'll bring angela back on in a
minute but brandon tell the think
community who you are
what you do and what question you have
for me okay so i'm brandon i run
the brimley games youtube channel mostly
we do
tutorial videos on how to play board and
card game so you don't have to read the
long instruction manual
yeah so my question is i have
a long-term business plan where i'm
going to be trying to design board and
card games
but i'm trying to get there with and my
question is how do i monetize right now
with only 100 subscribers to help me
then get to that long-term
plan yeah and are you tell me right now
do you have any
um monetization strategies set up or are
you
just starting so i've done the amazon
affiliate program
and i've gotten a few sales through
there but not not too many because it's
not i'm not doing any reviews so i think
that's probably why
yep there we go i was gonna say um if
you are already set up on amazon
um the type of content you create let me
just give you a scenario
if i'm a person i wanna come i wanna
learn about the game right i'm typing
that into the search bar so first off
you wanna make sure that your title has
the game in it you know what people are
searching right
but then the next video i would do would
be like my three
favorite holiday games my my five
top picks for games for kids under 12.
my does that make sense like you can do
board game reviews you can do
but but that list is critical so i would
start to really
get into youtube into the
search bar and say what are people
searching because
i can tell you as a mom and as someone
who runs a company and all those
i am searching board games i'm searching
different i'm searching not just board
games
i'm searching like we played this one
game called fidge
right it's not an actual board game but
it's like a online game
i didn't know how to play but you know
so so i want you to expand it a little
bit more
amazon affiliates is going to be one way
for sure um
but i would also be thinking about uh
these companies
approach them hi my name's brandon i run
this
channel we produce content around this
thing and i think
you align with my audience specifically
you know like really reach out as a
um as an entrepreneur brandon and say i
want to partner with you
i can review your game i can do this
thing whatever that looks like and
brandon
the sky's the limit you could be
partnering with brands like target
and walmart and right like it doesn't
have to just be
that game there's a lot of opportunity
beyond even just
amazon for where you can send people to
get stuff so does that help you
yeah that was super helpful thank you
awesome i'm so excited uh tell everyone
what your channel name is again
again it's brimley games thank you
awesome brandon so excited to have you
on today and i can't wait to see
your first review that you do on
your channel all right i'm gonna have
tony bring the next person on tony's in
the background he's gonna click them on
and i'm going to say hello to them as
they come on we've got
angela hi angela can you i can't hear
you for some can you hear me
i can hear you yeah i can't hear you i'm
in the back in the stream yard and i
can't hear you maybe i need to go out
and come back in or something
yeah let's do that and tony will bring
the next one on no worries hey
angela how you doing
hi hi we're having so much fun with
stream yard tonight
angela yeah i can tell can you hear me
there seems to be a little bit of a
delay
there must be there must be so tell me
uh who you are what your channel's about
and what question you have
okay well my well i am angela chan
and the name of my channel is someone
with gray hair
and what i do is i review only
silver gray and white wigs for ladies
yes um now that's a that's a trending
area right now i don't know if you know
you could see my hair is white
um but i started the youtube channel the
youtube channel because my hair was
thinning
and i'm a singer and so you're up front
didn't want to be up front with a bald
head thank god i still have some hair
so my problem that i had before i
started my channel was
i literally watched i'm embarrassed to
say
probably hundreds of hours and i still
wasn't getting what i needed to buy my
first wig
so one day i said oh my gosh you know
there have to be other women out i had
no desire to do anything like you guys
are teaching
none i didn't even know about sean
cannell or you
so but i thought you know if i'm having
this problem
there have to be a lot of other women
that are having this problem
i'm gonna start reviewing wigs so i i
probably spent three thousand dollars on
wigs
no lie i probably sent 75
of them back and then one day sean
cannell pops up in my feed
and i'm and i'm like oh no no i'm not
going to spend this money you know this
is a scam blah blah
and i cert i researched you guys and
honestly
it was a time with covid that i really
didn't have a lot of money i think
i sent an email and i said god bless you
guys but i can't do this but i couldn't
get you out of my head
so as you already know heather i bought
everything you've seen me before
everything
and so i have just been immersed in this
program
and now i'm putting up one video a week
okay so that's the background
so i guess what i want to know is
um am i am i really
on the right track i have bid iq i'm you
know i'm looking at all
yep i'm looking at all those stats and i
guess that's really my biggest question
probably most of us who are new i want
to be a six-figure business
i'm doing this full-time i'm not in real
estate anymore i had a successful real
estate business
closed it yeah um except for referrals
yeah so i am totally a thousand million
percent serious and by the way i just
have to give you a plug
anybody out there who's thinking even
remotely about buying this product
do not look back spend the money
find the money if you want a full-time
career in this
i mean who am i to say it i haven't done
it yet but i can see the writing on the
wall
i'm 60 something years old i know what
good business people look like
these are good business people heather
you're young enough to be my daughter
and i'm like respect respect okay so
there that's everything
oh well first off i just have to tell
you that that actually i'm like not
gonna cry but that means so much to me
because
um i just i first have angela i just
want to applaud you
for stepping out and for really seeing a
need
in the community you know and i think
that's what not a lot of people do
and especially because you're stepping
into a space which is beauty
that is not that brings up so much of
the insecurities that we have as humans
right so i just want to applaud you
and say i'm so proud that you even took
that step to start doing it
and i'm just so i feel lucky that i get
to watch this whole journey unfold right
from the very beginning and to have you
inside of our programs here inside
of think means the world to me because
you're the ideal client that we were
going after
so i'm just super honored and privileged
to even be talking to you today
um and to be able to help you in this
journey and i know you have had a
successful business before and so
here's one thing i know you've done it
once you're going to do it again
you know that's one thing so so you're
going to take the lessons you learned in
your other career and i know you're
going to apply that to this now
the question is am i on the right track
here's what i want to say
your first year even two years think
about it what it was like when you got
into real estate
it didn't just boom you're crazy
successful
and you're selling all this stuff and
you know it's like the grind
and you gotta pave the way and you gotta
make the videos and you've got to here's
the key
learn who she is and you already know
who she is because you've experienced it
but i want you to go deep into the
community i want you to be talking to
them i want you to become
the friend that they know that they need
and they can't find her
so is this is this a profitable proven
and profitable niche
absolutely you know how i know you spent
3 000
on wigs right like you already have
proven that this is
you've already proven this is somewhere
that um can hear me
you i'll keep going and you'll have this
on replay but you've already proven
that this is a niche where people spend
money so now
it's figuring out what she's actually
typing into the search bar and you may
actually be
uh what's called um before the curve
so in inside of business as you know
there's this curve of when something
hits and becomes
popular and your demographic your age
group
is just now starting to discover that
youtube is a place they can go
for answers you're already ahead of the
curve by being a leader that's making
videos
so i want you to know that and the
second thing is that i would be thinking
about
what articles is she reading where is
she
at right now because what you might need
to do
is collaborate with other um
other channels or businesses that are
serving the same audience but maybe not
in the exact same way so here's what
this looks like my friend jen
she runs an instagram group i do
youtube so we we're running to the same
people we know they need to be in the
same thing
and i can help her and she can help me
right so i need you
at the stage that you're at to really be
diving into
this whole um this whole phase where
you're in this
listening i say you want to turn your
customers into being your best
friends that's a key piece and you do
that
by just every person that's watching
your videos figure out did they have a
youtube channel
did they find you what facebook groups
is she in right now that you can be in
right like it's not like you're out
there just saying watch my videos but
what you're gonna do
is you're gonna be the friend the guy
the leader that's on the other side
of her questions and you know
the words that she's typing into the
search bar but she might even not know
the exact words yet
because now that you've been in this
role and you're in this industry
you're already tainted by the industry
words so be thinking about what is the
simple way that she's typing it in
because she might be searching hair loss
for women over 50.
she might be searching post-menopausal
hair loss like what is she typing in
where you would say oh that's not what
that is that's this thing or
maybe it's tied to a disease or maybe
it's tied to what does that make sense
like
you want to start really thinking but to
answer your question go back to the
beginning
are you doing this right are you are you
headed in the right direction
i would say yes and maybe today you're
helping with wigs
and maybe 10 years from now you're
helping her with financial planning in
that season or beauty in that season or
whatever that is but right now
you're choosing something where you can
break through
and then be able to help her in other
ways because
i can tell you from helping people set
up their cameras
from helping people learn how to do
youtube channels i have
moms and dads in my dms every day going
how do you work from home with your kids
how do you how do you meal plan and do
this i'm not talking about that on think
but because i've helped them with one
thing and they trust me
they'll now start asking me other
questions and other questions and other
questions that i can start to help them
in other ways in their life
so i hope that was helpful for you
angela i'm so grateful for you
for being in a part of our community and
for being a part of our
programs and i can't wait to see what
2021
looks like for you
oh i think you're muted
i love it she's going to figure it out
angela you are so awesome i'm so excited
that you're a part of our community
and uh thank you so much hey i want to
just shout out some people who are
watching live right now
we've got fire over 50 hey fire over 50
you should connect with angela i'm sure
you guys could collab if you're reaching
the same people
tracy's on right now we've got eating
the family eating and the family channel
uh we've got jessica i see you we've got
west
p world is on right now manny hey if
you're getting value out of this video
hit that like button and make sure
you're subscribed i'm going to bring on
maybe uh
let's see if angela's back on tony the
other angela
hey angela hi how are you heather so
great to see
you so great to see you as well um tell
everyone who you are and how
uh what what your channel is about and
what question you have for me today
thanks so much angela george and my
channel is the fashion master class
and so that and basically on that
channel is where i was
i've been teaching like tips and tricks
on how to start a fashion brand how to
get into the fashion industry
but which brings me to my question for
you heather
um in the course of the last 18 months
like i have been on this journey
and as you know i'm part of your
community and yes
kudos you know like all like love you
guys
and um i can't recommend them enough and
you know and just your community and
other communities and starting out
basically learning about the knowledge
business i basically started my journey
on basically how to you know package and
market my knowledge for maximum income
and impact and i've been on this journey
now for the past 18 months and i've done
a deep dive
into like all areas and i'm learning
about landing pages and i'm doing
lead magnets and um you know all the fun
stuff that we're doing it
and in in our inner circle and as other
courses i'm taking these digital course
academy with amy porterfield
i mean you name it i've basically taken
a deep dive
university style mini mba for the past
12 months since i closed my fashion
brands
and what i've come to and it's really
just i feel like
everything's leading this way is that
aside from being
i really feel my the niche that i'm
going after it was it's too small like
people that want to start a fashion
brand and i want to be able to monetize
my channel
and so i you know i worked with actually
with sean and sean gave me like an
amazing idea for a lead
magnet to go to my customers where i
have my my
lists basically my email is what am i
low hanging fruit
you know push pro you know push things
out to them with affiliates and this and
that
but the overarching thing for me is that
i really want to help individuals
over 40 and i might even say like over
45 or
you know to basically package and market
their knowledge for maximum income and
impact like what i'm doing
but i want to be helping others to do
that because i've done all the studying
and i've
immersed myself and i'm already actually
coaching two people
that i know that are in you know one
person is a friend she's 52 she's got a
dog training brick and mortar business
that she wants to take online
and my sister-in-law who's a fitness
expert who does you know
in-home training she's 67 and she wants
to start a youtube channel
and i'm like i'm taking them we're going
in zoom i'm opening up i'm doing screen
share
i'm showing them ever i mean i love that
you and sean say like
teach what you are learning that's the
way you kind of assimilate it
and i'm i'm like bing bing look at this
channel success leaves clues i'm like
look at how many views look at how many
subs to the views and look
and look this is an amazing look they
had this many ninety thousand this is
like 265.
so you know what's this can we do trend
surfing you know do a video like that
dude the reason
everything you guys have taught me like
over and over and over and
you guys are like in my head all the
time literally and it's a good thing
yeah and it's a good thing um so yeah so
i'm thinking i
you know the fashion master class i feel
is becoming like it needs to become
something else so i'm wondering how and
plus you know i wanna and i also need to
i need money for the mission like john
always says and you say
so you know how can i make that
transition with my current sorry i think
i went on but anyway how can i make that
transition with my current channel
i love it that was a great explanation
and angela again thank you for being a
part of our community i just love that
you're always on you're always here
you're always
learning you're an action taker and i
love that so much so
i i'm your coach so i'm gonna coach you
okay so
um so here's what i would say uh you
need money for the mission so
you know that in inner circle our steps
are you need a proven right you need to
master your niche
you need a significant uh piece of
content we we also need to
get to income quickly what's the fastest
way to income right and you want to
teach from what you know
but at the same time i need you even if
it's a
10 course even if it's a 25 course
whatever that looks like
in order to build that authority to help
other women
go and do what you want them like you're
teaching them to do
in order to do that i also need you to
have a course
that could be making money that could be
right like
in the mission you're already in the
mission but that you have the
credibility
when you start teaching other women that
stuff so
i am a visionary angela i know you're a
visionary and i
underestimate what i can do in 10 years
because i want to do it all in one year
and so if you know that's actually where
i want to go if i if
let me be honest with you i love what
i'm doing here i love the mission that
we've
what we're doing at think media i mean
this is
sean and heather and omar this is our
baby right like what we've created and
done
but i'm talking about youtube clarity
and i want to like change the foster
care system you know i mean like
that's where i want to go and so i know
that i need to put in the time i need to
help an audience i need to really
understand what i'm doing
first before i can use that influence
into the next thing
and so my goal to you is actually stay
on the track that you're on
still teach you're that's fun right
because you're getting to have those
handles
you're getting to see you you are
coaching you can even offer that as a
service
that's fine um but even if it's not the
fashion brand even if you're like you
know what
i want to expand outside of that i want
to help women get clarity
on where they want to go on their
mission rather than saying
i want them to create online courses
maybe the first step that you've done
is actually figured out how to get
clarity in your second
in your second round of business you
know like you've already had successful
businesses so how do you pivot
out into a new business right like you
could be thinking about that
but as entrepreneurs as you know we have
to stay stay
disciplined to the mission and if you
know that that's a serve
that an audience you can serve and you
can make money
now then i want you to do that first
because once you get that rabbit going
right you chase that one rabbit
then you can go chase the next rabbit
and the next rabbit and the next rabbit
so
i would say as your coach that i know
you've worked so hard to get to this
point
that what happens so often is we get all
the way to the point right before we
could make the money
and we go oh but this shiny new object
looks great oh this shiny new object
looks great and then we're like
how come nothing's working because we
keep changing what the thing is so i
want you to
go all in finish the one thing first
and then from the experience you had of
building it of doing it of marketing it
of taking all the education you've had
then go out and start helping with the
next step does that help
yes and no so what should i do with my
channel like what type of content should
i be putting on my channel i guess no it
helps but i
i like what's my next action step with
my channel then
yeah so what are you currently doing
well right now i was about to post i
started like this interview series i was
interviewing people
in the fashion industry in different
various facets like i was just editing a
video for some
that started like a sustainable thing
with vintage clothing and he's selling
on instagram
and then i someone i mentored i did last
time and then i i
actually talked to some people i'm
planning on interviewing that
are into sustainability and just
different a costume designer like just
different facets of the industry
but this isn't like where it's not the
this isn't the money trail for me
where you want to be so you're so okay
so so you're discovering that that
actually
isn't where you want to be is that
that's more so what you're saying versus
the shiny object i need to evaluate
which one
you know is it that you're like you know
what this actually could be a better
route
if you want to pivot and you want and
you're like you know what i want to go
that direction here's what i would
recommend
i'd recommend you doing an interview
channel where you
interview online course creators you
interview women who are rocking it you
interview men who are rocking it
you start interviewing them because what
that does is that actually
puts you on a playing field where it
builds your influence
so you're saying i you know i've been
successful here i've been doing this
thing
because you are so early on it's not
like you've built like this giant
you know 100 000 subscribers and you're
pivoting out of it i know you've worked
at this
but if you're like no heather i'm
switching i'm no i'm going down this
road
i want to leave that piece behind i want
to move to this new thing
if it's not a shiny object and you're
like no deeply inside
i know that this is the path i want to
go for the next three five years
then i would actually start interviewing
because instead of teaching out what you
haven't done
what you're doing is you're interviewing
what they have done
right yeah yeah it's like it's they
would like call it like it's like
brokering the knowledge so if you're not
the expert you bring the expert yeah i
know exactly
no i agree i exactly and the thing is it
is on my heart to help women
who are afraid of the tech who are
afraid of and i'm and i'm overcoming
those fears little by little so i feel
like i can
you know help them with the overwhelm
and what do i do and so many ideas like
i've been through all that and i finally
feel like a lot of my
roads are converging at this point
exactly and i would also be really
mindful about who you're bringing on so
one of my mentors chalene johnson says
is always always
um be always think about who you're
trying to follow
meaning when i bring people into my
world for my homeschool channel
they are also entrepreneurs because i
value that i think that's really
valuable so i would also make sure like
what's the criteria to even get on your
show
if that makes sense meaning make sense
maybe you don't interview the 20 year
old who does it in his bedroom you know
like
maybe you interview someone who has had
a successful career
turned the channel you know turned and
pivoted like maybe
that's a whole thing of like pivoting
your plan online or like
that's a i don't know but does that make
sense like the idea they've done
something once
they either left that or they came
online and they created a successful
course and you're in
amy's porter fields community so there's
i mean
thousands of people who have created
courses literally
literally 4 200 people yes i mean her
community is amazing
but if you put your stamp in the ground
if you put your flag in the ground and
say
this is what i want to do i want to
bring light to this community
of women over 40 who are killing it
online
that's an amazing opportunity because
it's only going to grow
the online course creation space is just
getting started
it's only going to grow and smart
intelligent
professional women like you are seeing
the opportunity so
it's it so okay so my advice as a coach
was giving you hard course
or giving you hard correction and then
saying okay pivot that's fine but if
that's the way you want to go
yeah i love it thank you so much heather
it makes so much sense and i love what
you're saying like don't exactly don't
go for the person in the you know doing
like the instagram like vintage clothing
go for the person who's literally had
success
and no i think that honestly i got what
i came for this is
excellent thank you angela so much so
much
so excited for you bye bye awesome i
hope that helped hey
i can be a coach who changes my mind too
right i mean i only had a sliver of the
information i've known angela's journey
but here's the thing you could you can
pivot in business but
at the same time if you are just chasing
this shiny object this is an
this is a very self-awareness type of
question
if you get to the point where you're
almost going to do it
and then you do something else that's a
thing that's a reflection of
do you feel like you are worthy of this
do you know that you can
go deeper like as entrepreneurs we keep
wanting to pivot
but in angela's case she's so brand new
like she's come
off of such a successful career that
she's dabbling around
figuring out what it is she wanted to do
her first idea was to still tie it to
her
to her current career uh that she had
just finished
but really she's seeing the opportunity
of where she could go in the next decade
and applying those business principles
that she had learned so
i hope that helps uh and angela is gonna
kill it uh
fire over 50. man let's celebrate the
women over
50 who are rocking it on youtube i can't
wait to see what you guys do because
you're some smart women so
i'm excited all right we're going to
bring one more person on tony's going to
grab
one more person for me and then again if
you have not taken our think master
class that actually is going to be your
next
move so after this stream is over after
you watch this video
that's your next move you want to go to
thinkmasterclass.com it's a one hour
class
and during that class sean the uh
founder and ceo of think media
walks you through step by step the three
secrets
that he learned with how to dominate on
youtube how to be successful on youtube
we talk about
what niches are good we talk about what
video ideas you should do we talk about
why now is the time to go all in on
youtube and if you felt
lost if you felt like you didn't quite
know how to do this youtube thing we're
here for you you just saw i mean i
i did not tell angela or angela to say
those things
like they're a part of our community and
we are here to help you and serve you we
want to help
10 000 people create a full-time living
doing what they love
with the power of video and make an
impact in the world and that's exactly
what those women are doing so if that is
your next step you want to go to
thinkmasterclass.com we're going to
bring one more person on tony in the
background
hi hi mari how are you good how are you
sorry for the um it's really really
um hot here and then
there you go hey how are you can you
help me i can't how are you doing is it
marie good
yeah murray yeah and um
my question is i posted um a comment
on a vla group the other day and then
you uh responded back
but um recently i decided to
niche down to my cooking channel
to moms with little kids yes my son
has been like you know teaching this
unique cooking method
uh cooking process which japanese woman
moms use in japan
to help kids you know establish a
healthy cooking i mean healthy eating
habits and then
thus you know prevent the obesity and
then all that
and what i would really teach is not
necessarily how to prevent
kids to be a picky eater but then like
you know
how to ex um how to put together
like healthy meals easily so that
these benefit would follow now the thing
is i don't have any
kids and so that's one of the uh you
know
um you know imposter syndrome kicks in
on him
here and there and then also i have my
biggest problem
is that um keyword search
i feel like i'm i
my method is not necessarily teaching a
fixed
recipe i my approach is like teaching
something
flexible enough so that they can do a
little bit of a
you know planned a prep instead of meal
plan
and then you know kind of make have a
uh make some um you know uh building
blocks
which you can use the rest of the week
so that you can put together
like you know meals really easily in
like 10 to 15 minutes
for the rest of the week even though you
know all of a sudden you
realize that oh my god it's too hot i
don't want to eat that and then you can
still change uh change it and everything
but then you know when it comes to
keyword swords it's been
really hard it's either like really high
volume
and then you know like well i end up
with like you know vid iq
like score 19 or something yes and then
my real um
difference maker is how to turn
a leftover into something completely
different okay but then when i
do this keyboard search with leftovers
it's like
non-existent i mean even though there's
like a lot of uh views on like you know
some other um channels and everything
but then when i just see the weird iq
thing
it's just so low and then as it's like
nobody's
checking but then you know i have done
this in person
and then people who i have been having
problem attracting clients but then
those people who actually tried my
method
really really loved it because it works
yeah so i was wondering uh what kind of
wisdom you can share with me
yes well first off i want to hit the
first uh part mari
you have a heart to serve and there's a
community that you want to serve now
just because
you're making recipes that are going to
affect the next generation
to me i don't think disqualifies you
because you personally don't have
children i think that
having a heart to serve that community
having to serve
mothers um doesn't mean that you
personally have to be a mother
to show her how to do great recipes or
what what that looks like so yeah
because i have a lot of uh experience
with the method itself i mean i
developed it myself
but using what the japanese mom used and
then i was born and raised in japan and
the rest of my family and then friends
lives in japan so
i'm very familiar with that yes yeah so
i just want to empower you to know
that you have a skill that can serve an
audience and so
so i want you to know that for me this
is my
my one opinion but my opinion i think
that sounds self
okay anyway so that matters what does
that even mean
um just from someone who has been on
this side as a mother i would not
disqualify you from helping me because
you are not if that makes sense
so i would say you got this now keyword
research
there's uh um there is something in
marketing that i want you to write down
and i want everybody
watching this to write this down it's
called the chocolate covered
carrot you're like okay why would i want
a chocolate covered carrot hear me okay
chocolate covered carrot
type that in the comments right now if
you're here chocolate covered carrot
here's what this looks
like you might be typing things into the
search bar
like leftovers yeah
and that makes sense because maybe
someone would come to the search bar and
they'd say like
what to cook with chicken leftovers
right that is that's like
that's not necessarily where they are
when they're
starting because in order to get to
leftovers you should have cooked
something
right so that makes sense so what
chocolate covered carrot is
it means that the carrot is actually the
style of cooking that you do
that's the um that's the the thing that
they don't actually want to eat the
carrot and you're like
okay heather what they want is the
chocolate
like here's what this looks like in
youtube let me put this into a better
context
in youtube people say how do i get more
views how do i get more subscribers how
do i grow my channel
that's the chocolate they want the
chocolate
the carrot is i'm gonna come to you mari
and i'm gonna say
well you need to produce one video a
week you need to do a lot of keyword
research you need to make thumbnails you
need to understand titles you need to
learn the youtube algorithm you need to
grow a business you should become a
business owner right like
that's the carrot people people don't
want six pack abs
they're not typing that in going how do
i get six pack abs and i'm not
the the trainer is not coming to them
saying you get six pack abs
by sitting on the couch eating bonbons
no
by eating right by doing all these
things so how do i apply this to your
channel here's what i apply this to
you have a unique style of cooking and
you want to help
with uh helping mothers and
children eat better correct
and it's a japanese style cooking no i
mean it's
not japanese style okay recipe but then
the masala japanese style which is not
known outside of japan because
everything is written in japanese yes
yes
so it's things like three chicken
recipes
under 15 minutes that's what they're
searching
and or it's things like how to help a
picky eater
even though that's not necessarily what
you're doing i i remember there was this
book
um by uh jerry seinfeld's wife she has
an entire business
where all she did was she made regular
recipes
and she pureed the vegetables oh yeah
yeah yeah
yeah she she hit the stuff she hit it
right
that's what moms are searching for
they're certain they're searching for
does that make sense and what is to do
that's the chocolate they want to know
how do i get my kid to eat more
vegetables
okay that's what you're typing in and
you're going to say the carrot is
this is a unique style of cooking this
is presenting them
with this variety this is doing these
three things and from what you make with
this one recipe
you can also make these three other
recipes at this time right
so it's really understanding that she is
actually before
the point of of typing specifically into
the search box
leftover recipes she's going to need
leftover recipes she doesn't know she
needs that yet
so when i think about where you are here
what is the mother's struggle at the
time
she wants to get her kids to eat healthy
she's coming into this saying
how do i make healthy recipes for kids
how do i make
simple easy recipes how do i make what
should a three-year-old be eating like
she's asking those type of questions so
you want to make sure the videos that
you're creating or
answering the question but your job mari
is to educate her
on the style that you're doing that's
where your
job comes in when you hook line and
sinker with the topic the title and the
thumbnail does that help you
yeah so question like
what does three-year-old would eat
that's when i feel like i don't know i
mean like some of the
three-year i mean like i know the
japanese three-year-old would eat
but then some americans three-year-old
seems to be a lot more picky
yeah and actually that's the reason why
i want to start early because
i know that the reason why american kids
are picky
is because the parents are not feeding
as many
um vegetables and then dishes at the
young age
right mom would say like i don't think
you're an alexis
and then they they start with that
conversation and then it's like of
course
like i don't think i like it because it
doesn't have chocolate on it
yeah i know it's yes yes and so i'm just
that was that's just me throwing out
where i'm saying
what is she typing in she's typing in
questions about where she personally is
as a mother with how she wants to help
her children so yeah in order for
someone to type in here's what i want
you to think
in order for someone to type in healthy
kid
recipes let's just say that there's a
lot of pre-qualifying things that that
person already believes
like their belief system is that they
want to feed
their children healthy foods yeah so
so your job though as the educator on
your channel
is to answer those questions what are
healthy
recipes for kids and that's just a
generic one i want you to go deeper
but your job is to answer that question
with your methodology when someone types
in how to get more views on youtube
there's 50 youtube coaches answering
that question
my job is that when they click on our
videos
is to convince them that my strategy is
the best strategy
because i want them to be successful so
does that make sense so when someone
types in
best or easy recipes for children
with carrots with carrots or whatever
then your job is to say i believe in
this methodology i think this is the
best way this is why japanese children
are like this and american children are
like
yeah you have but that is i hope that
helps you mario i'm gonna get to the
next person but i hope that helps get
the ideas flowing and again this with
youtube is
all about trial and error you're going
to make those make videos make videos
because then you're going to find the
thing that breaks through you're going
to find out
how when i talk about cheese
my views go up when i talk about
broccoli
my views go down so what are you going
to talk more about i'm going to talk
more about cheese even if
that makes sense so you're just
beginning sages you're going to get it
uh mari thank you so much for being on
today
you're welcome i was about to thank you
that's happening live you got that live
this is what happens live you're going
to
that's what's going to happen well hey
thank you so much for being on today and
again your next step is to go to
thinkmasterclass.com
if you want to take our free one hour
master class and we'll see you
in the next video bye